there are 15 different breathing Styles
in Demon Slayer including Sun breathing
the first breathing style and the one
from which all the other styles are
derived it was created by the strongest
Demon Slayer in history yorichi
tsugikuni six main Styles emerged from
the original breath of the Sun including
water flame Thunder Wind Stone and moon
breathing additional breathing styles
were then derived from these ones flower
and serpent breathing were both derived
from water breathing and then insect
breathing was derived from flower
breathing as such insect breathing is
the style that is furthest removed from
the original Sun breathing there are
three degrees of separation between them
in addition love breathing was derived
from flame breathing sound breathing was
derived from Thunder breathing and both
beast and Mist breathing were derived
from wind breathing if you want more
demonstrator content subscribe to anime
uproar right now